[موسيقى]
موجز الاخبار من قناه الجزيره اهلا بكم
اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاد فتى
فلسطيني بعد اصابته برصاصه في الراس
اطلقها جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال
اقتحام مخيم بلاطه الشرقيه مدينه نابلس مع
اصفر ايضا عن اصابه ثلاثه اخرين
اخرجت السلطات الاسرائيليه عن عميد الاسرى
الفلسطينيين كريم يونس بعد ان انهى فتره
حكمه البالغه 40 عاما في سجون الاحتلال
وقد تتوجه يونس الى مسقط راسه في منطقه
المثلث داخل الخط الاخضر
قبيله جلسه لمجلس الامن الدولي بشان
انتهاكات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في القدس
اجتمع اهم مجلس سفراء العرب لدى الامم
المتحده وممثلون عن منظمه التعاون
الاسلاميه مع رئيس مجلس الامن وقد تركزت
النقاشات على الاستياء العربي والاسلامي
ازاء اقتحام الاقصى واكد مصدر فلسطيني
للجزيره ان مجلس الامن سيبحث ايضا ملف
اعتداءات المستوطنين على المقابر المسيحيه
بالقدس
هذا واقل مندوب فلسطين لدى الامم المتحده
رياض منصور انا ما تريده فلسطين من جلسه
مجلس الامن الدوليه اليوم هو الوقوف في
وجهه حكومه نتنياهو المتطرفه وعدم السماح
لها بفرض ايرادتها على المجتمع الدولي
اجراءات احاديه تقود الوضع الراهنه خلال
اماكن المقدسه بالقدس كما دعا المتحدث
باسم الخارجيه الالمانيه رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه للالتزام بالوضع القائم في
الاماكن المقدسه
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن دخول
الفرقه الجديده الادميرال جورجيس الخدمه
كما اعلنت عن اطلاق تجريبيا لصاروخ سيركون
الاسرع من الصوت وقال الرئيس الروسي ان
الفرقه الجديده ستحمل روسيا من التهديدات
الخارجيه
في المقابل قال وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
دي متروكوليبا انه قدم البدء بالفعل في
نقل انظمه باتريات الامريكيه الى اوكرانيا
انه سيتم نشرها والاستفاده منها في اقرب
وقت للرد على الاعتداءات الروسيه
بدوره قال رئيس الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه ان
بلاده تخطط لشن هجوم كبير في الربيع
المقبل على مواقع تمركز القوات الروسيه
خفق مجلس النواب الامريكي في انتخاب رئيس
جديد له بعد ست جولات من التصويت على مدار
يومين اجل المجلس جلساته حتى ظهر اليوم
الخميس بتوقيت المحلي وقال الرئيس عبيدا
انما وصفها بالفوضى التي صاحبت عمليه
التصويت محرجه وتؤثر بشكل سلبي على صوره
الى اللقاء